good afternoon and welcome to the March
8th disaster information specialist
webinar we are very excited that you are
at our webinar and we know that some of
you are experiencing some weather let's
just say and we wanted to let you know
that we have resources for whether we
see I always forget that my that I have
to open everything up in Chrome so let
me go ahead and open this up in Chrome
and I would recommend that you go to our
disaster lych database and enter in
winter and cold I had a better that's
not the right one if you maybe Robin you
can find the link for me for the search
for winter weather I forget that my
screen won't share on them on Firefox so
while Robin is looking for that and I'm
sorry I apologize about that I did want
to say that the National Library of
Medicine has released the National
Library of Medicine strategic plan which
is called a platform for my biomedical
discovery and data powered health and so
Jen is going to put in the chat box the
link to the blog post that are the
national library of medicine director
patty Brennan posted about the strategic
plan with the focus of the strategic
plan on data science and also in her
blog post she includes information that
the National Institutes of Health has
issued a draft of their strategic plan
which is also the data science plan
and along with that plan they also have
a request for information seeking input
from all stakeholders so that input is
due April second and we would highly
recommend you taking a look at the both
plans they have to of course work
together in collaboration with each
other and and if you have input please
please take a look at that here's the
link to winter or extreme cold for those
of you who are out there working in the
cold shoveling helping rescue people you
can take a look at our disaster lit
websites and our database I'm sorry and
you can find some of these resource
resources on how to protect people and
emergency preparedness and severe
weather things like that and finally it
is International Women's Day and so we
do have tried this again
we do have a page on our website for I
want to get the exact right pregnant
women and disasters and emergencies so
in honor of International Women's Day
take a look at this webpage and and have
some fun I'm going to stop sharing my
screen and I'm going to move the
presenter ball to Melissa and have her
take over
she melissa is the she's a nurse with
the master's in public health she's the
director of the division of national
healthcare preparedness programs at the
HHS office of the assistant secretary
for preparedness and response and I'm I
know I'm very excited to hear
Melissa's presentation and please use
the chat box to put any questions that
you have for Melissa in the chat box and
we will keep track of the questions and
at the end of the presentation we'll
make sure that Melissa has access to all
of your questions so I'm going to mute
myself and turn it over to Alyssa thank
you so much I really appreciate it and
thanks so much for taking the time today
to have me present about the hospital
preparedness program and the CMS
emergency preparedness rule to you I'm
the director of the division of national
healthcare preparedness programs at
asper which has a few programs under the
most visible is the hospital
preparedness program which will mainly
be spending most of the time today
talking about so if you give you just
those who are not familiar with the
hospital preparedness program that I'll
be calling HPP throughout the
presentation it is a cooperative
agreement grant program that's
administered by us hereinafter and is
the only source of federal funding for
health care delivery system readiness
many of you may have heard of the MMR s4
from years ago and other programs
throughout the federal government that
were also aimed at healthcare
preparedness but those have since gone
away and the only program left for what
is largely a private health care
delivery system in the u.s. here is is
the HPP program we are really charged
with preparing the healthcare system to
save lives during emergencies that
exceed the day to day capacity of the
health and emergency response systems in
the United States we think it's really
important to build our emergency
healthcare response system off of a day
to day systems because we all know that
healthcare providers and healthcare
facilities rely on each other every
single day and what we need to be able
to do is basically take those
relationships and sum up put them on
steroids during an emergency not be
spending the time creating new
relationships or planning in new
relationships that we don't cultivate
every day that we would expect to turn
on during an emergency because I think
we all know that that wouldn't really
work so we do this by developing what we
call Regional Healthcare coalition's and
these are groups of healthcare providers
and facilities as well as other
organizations and governmental community
partners that are really charged with
bringing these really diverse facilities
and organizations together and we all
know they're really competitive with
each other especially in metropolitan
areas or suburban areas you'll see
commercials on television every day
trying to essentially recruit patients
for what are in many cases somewhat
elective type of procedures whether we
see you know cardiac sensing commercials
or whether we even see commercials aimed
at new mothers and fathers who will be
delivering babies all trying to vie for
their market share but that's the last
thing that we want to do during an
emergency we want to make sure that
these competitive organizations that
have very differing priorities and and
obviously are on a day to day basis
hesitant to share kind of
business-related information with each
other we want to break down those walls
and make sure that we can do that
quickly during a
emergency and that they can actually
work together not as competing interests
we promote a sustainable Kisan improving
patient outcomes and we make sure that
we try to decrease the need for
supplemental state and federal resources
during emergencies whether that's in
terms of funding or even just in terms
of our own assistance because we really
do believe that all emergencies are
local and that it's really important
that the local delivery system be able
to maintain both capacity and capability
to the extent that they can so for those
who are familiar with HPE and what I'll
say in the early days the program
started in 2002 right after 9/11 and the
anthrax attacks and when I say the early
days I mean really about the first
decade of the program or so for about
the first decade of the program the
funding went to awardees and we are two
hundred and fifty five million dollars a
year program going to 62 awardees those
awardees are our state public health
department's of the 50 states they are
for directly funded cities Washington DC
New York City Chicago and LA County and
they are also are really associated
Basin as well as territories and the
funding goes to those health departments
and then from those health departments
they are currently charged with funding
those healthcare coalition's that I just
spoke about but in the earlier years of
the program the money went to those
health departments and then those health
departments were charged with only
funding hospitals so many of them took
their total awards and they would divide
it up among the number of hospitals
through some kind of a formula about
number of easy visits a year or a number
of total beds or number of cepheid's and
really gave it to those facilities for
their own individual preparedness needs
a lot of those preparedness needs were
equipment purchases many hospitals
weren't planning for large surges of
patients prior to 911 and just didn't
have both the specialty kinds of
equipment that we were thinking about
whether that was personal protective
equipment for biological attacks or they
didn't have the volume of equipment they
would need to account for a mass surge
so we saw
of purchasing of equipment and
pharmaceutical caches for prophylaxis
and for treatment and other kinds of
emergency supplies and equipment we we
got I'd like to say we got a little bit
smarter go through living through h1n1
and various other kinds of emergencies
where we saw that the key to a
well-prepared healthcare system is
actually those healthcare facilities
working together not just preparing them
individually in 2009 h1n1 we would often
go to various different kinds of
hospitals in a metropolitan area and we
walk into one of them and that hospital
would tell us we don't know what we're
going to do we only have one bed and one
ventilator left and what happens if we
get to patients we're going to have to
make a really terrible decision about
you know whether we take someone off a
ventilator or if we just you know deny
the access to a ventilator to an
incoming patient or what it is that we
do and these are terrible decisions that
we have to make because we're so scarce
on resources and then we would walk a
couple blocks down literally one in one
city it was a 13 blocks down the road
and go into their ICU and they had you
know 22 beds available and they had
plenty of ventilators they even had an
ECMO
that was not currently being used and we
said to ourselves there's a problem here
yes these are competing healthcare
systems these two hospitals are owned by
different business partners but there is
no reason that this one hospital should
feel that they are so at capacity that
they don't have any idea that there's
tremendous amounts of capacity just down
the road we've got to get them to work
together and another example that was
really apparent to us was the igloo tis
2012 derecho
now the derecho was a kind of a storm
that's really rapidly developing and
came here to the mid-atlantic area it
very quickly in the summer and knocked
out power to almost all fall healthcare
facilities hospitals were certainly on
generator but we learned two things that
were very important then and one was
regarding dialysis patients the dialysis
facilities since this was kind of a no
notice event it wasn't like a hurricane
where we knew it was coming the dialysis
facilities didn't have time to do any
kind of pre dialysis nor did they have
time to kind of notify their page
and tell them to go to a different
facility so a lot of them didn't have
generators and a lot of them just simply
shut down and a lot of the patients who
not even that long ago maybe five or
seven years ago would have been in
patients in a hospital because they were
truly that sick are now living in the
community and living at home every day
because of advances in medical
technology and simply changes in our
healthcare delivery system and these
patients require power they require
electricity to be able to plug in the
equipment that they rely on to stay
alive and without those two things what
we kept hearing from the hospitals in
this mid-atlantic area that got hit by
distr ratio was that the emergency
departments were just completely
completely swamped they were full of
patients that did not need to be there
dialysis patients that live at home
every day and go for dialysis three
times a week and patients who live at
home every day and just needed a plug
that's all the same needed but they had
to be admitted to a hospital because
there was no one else that could provide
services for them so those hospital beds
were being taken that by these patients
who obviously had a need but certainly
not an acute medical care need and then
they were swamped by people who were
actually either survivors or victims of
the storm themselves whether it was
downed trees that caused trauma
accidents or people who really had
emergencies heart attacks will happen
even during emergencies strokes will
happen and there were no beds for these
individuals so we said we really need to
figure out a way to get the whole
healthcare system working together and
as a reason HPT is no longer just about
hospitals anymore we're about all of
healthcare all different types of
healthcare facilities and partners all
planning together and we also switched
at that time away from not just changing
from a hospital to a coalition model but
away from what we call equipment
purchases to more of a capabilities
based approach to planning so we'll the
way I like to think about that is
regardless of whether you're talking
about a natural disaster like a tornado
or hurricane or a infectious disease
outbreak there are some basic
capabilities that need to be done across
the entire healthcare system in order to
be sure that we're ready
so again regardless of what caused the
emergency the tornado
we're the infectious disease outbreak we
need to make sure that we're all
communicating with each other we need to
make sure that we all are aware of what
each other's resources are because we're
going to need resources during both
those two types of events even though
they're very different we need to make
sure that we can continue to provide
health care delivery services one which
would be structural reason why we might
not be able to in a tornado the other
being that we are limited in staffing
the infectious disease outbreak because
our staff might be getting ill and then
the last is obviously both of those and
everything in between
require and need to plan and respond to
a medical surge so what we like to think
of our capabilities are inside of each
of those is guidance for the individual
facility guidance for the coalition and
guidance for the jurisdiction on what
their roles are in making sure that the
US healthcare delivery system is able to
plan for and respond to an emergency and
kind of what we call the ideal or the
gold standard we don't say that these
capabilities are what HPP needs to do
because again with 255 million dollars
as a program influencing a multi
trillion dollar health care systems
there's no way 255 million dollars alone
can pay for what's needed to do to build
all of these capabilities we believe
that if you have your facilities or
coalition's in your jurisdictions
well-planned for these capabilities
you're about 80 percent of the way there
and that doesn't matter what type of
Hazard it is but at the same time some
hazards are just really unique so if you
take something like Ebola you need all
of the things that you'll see on the
right-hand side of the screen you need
all four of those kind of capabilities
but we needed some really specific
things as well so we call that about the
20% pivot we needed a specialized bio
containment units we needed much much
much more training really specialized
kinds of personal protective equipment
we needed a very intensive type care
that the fur virus that had never yet
been seen in the United States so
there's definitely a need for every
emergency to have its own flavor and
planning factors put into it but again
the core of all this still requires a
lot of the same baseline capabilities no
matter what the emergency is
so here I'll share with you again the
four capabilities and if you as I'm
speaking just kind of quickly glance
through the goals no need to read them
entirely but again the foundation for
healthcare and medical readiness is a
really somewhat fancy way of saying that
you need to create a very strong and
sustainable healthcare coalition that
has strong relationships with each other
is able to do what we call a hazard
vulnerability analysis and determine
what the hazards are that are unique to
that small regions every regions got
very different hazards obviously Florida
is going to have something very
different to plan for than North Dakota
and we want to make sure that the
Coalition is focusing since obviously
resources for preparedness are very
limited that they're focusing on truly
what those hazards most likely hazards
are and what the primary gaps are that
they have so that they're addressing
their gaps through planning training
exercises and enhancing resources and
managing those resources when necessary
the second capability is health care and
medical response coordination and this
is really recognizing that healthcare
coalition's even though they are not
formal entities like you know a
government entity may be that they do
have a role in what we call the esf-8
process the emergency support function
process which is the government's way of
managing health and medical emergencies
at both the federal state and local
level typically prior to healthcare
coalition's what you might see is a
health and medical desk at an office of
emergency management's Emergency
Operations Center so the county or the
local Emergency Operations Center will
have a health and medical desk staff by
one or two people and during an
emergency like the derecho that I just
talked about you would then have every
healthcare organization you know it's
219 Dale's of facilities 120 nursing
homes numerous outpatient centers
obviously the hospitals all calling
those one or two people at that esf-8
desk to report their status and report
their needs what they need from the
Office of Emergency Management that gets
incredibly incredibly cumbersome for
that esf-8 desk even if you were staff
it was many more people it's still
different cumbersome
and the other challenge is that while
the Office of Emergency Management both
of the state and local level is
phenomenal at providing resources the
resources that they are charged with
providing are not necessarily healthcare
resources they are things like food and
fuel for generators which can obviously
be helpful in healthcare bottled water
really basic necessities that's when
you're talking about health care then
the needs for healthcare resources go
far beyond those types of resources I'll
give you an example here we had an area
Michigan that lost telemetry the
telemetry in their hospitals and weren't
able to do central cardiac monitoring
and they certainly could have called the
Office of Emergency Management and
recorded that but I can guarantee you
there is no Office of Emergency
Management probably anywhere in the
United States that has a stockpile of
cardiac monitors ready to deploy to a
hospital the only way that hospital is
going to be able to keep those patients
there and not evacuate them was by
working with EMS to get transport
monitors either off the ambulances or
from their stockpiles into that hospital
and by working with the healthcare
facilities to get any available portable
monitors into that hospital to keep
those patients there obviously our goal
is to not have to move patients unless
it's an absolute necessity so that's
again why healthcare coalition's can now
coordinate with each other through
information sharing platforms whether
those are web-based or radios or
multiple redundancies to take into
account that some may go down during an
emergency to be able to share with each
other the resource needs and the
requirements of each of these facilities
have and their general operating status
because even if you can't fulfill those
needs
just having visibility and awareness at
a healthcare facility in your general
area is having some trouble it's very
helpful to have knowing that everything
somewhat trickles downhill and that will
probably be your facility fairly soon so
getting a little bit of a heads-up on
planning is always incredibly helpful
the third capability is continuity of
healthcare service delivery and this is
again where I had mentioned it with the
tornado and the infectious disease
outbreak we want to keep healthcare
services running let's healthcare
services stop running we
are in a really really bad place because
all emergencies in this country are in
all emergencies anywhere have a health
impact and so if we don't have health
care services running and we have to
take those out and move people over to
the town next door to get them that that
is a huge impact because many healthcare
services are required in a very timely
manner especially during emergencies so
this capability is giving guidance to
individual health care facilities and
coalition's about how to provide
uninterrupted and ideally optimal
medical care to all populations even if
facilities are damaged or the
infrastructure itself is disabled and
this is about keeping health care
workers well-trained and well educated
and safe to make sure that they're able
to continue to provide care during an
emergency as well as we all know that
the personnel resource of health care
facilities is really what keeps those
facilities running and then the last
piece is medical surge and medical surge
has two components one that we call a
tape of capability side and the other of
capacity side the capacity side is a
little bit easier to understand so I'll
go through that first and capacity is
truly just that adding capacity
increasing your numbers so if we have a
train derailment in an area knowing that
if you're going get another 200 patients
in a small rural area that you have a
way to increase your capacity inside of
your facilities either by through strong
coordination or in some cases that's not
possible and you turn it non-traditional
in patient care areas into inpatient
care areas whether those are more
outpatient care areas or Packers or
other parts of the facility into a
inpatient care area so the capacity side
is just that the capability side is a
little bit more difficult and I'll use
Ebola here as an example again if bola
was not a capacity issue here in this
country we did have plenty of beds
obviously for the patients but
healthcare the health care system in
this country was still incredibly
overwhelmed because the emergency was so
different that it really text our
capability to handle it so that's where
we have now in this new set of
capabilities added some new things
related to capacity so special
populations particularly Pediatrics is
burn
cbrne chemical biological radiological
nuclear and explosive types of terrorism
that might cause a surge on the
healthcare system those again are both a
capacity as well as a capability issue
since we don't see those kinds of
injuries and in some cases with regard
to pediatrics we don't always see
pediatrics at adult healthcare
facilities but yet during a real
emergency there will be a need to make
sure we can support that so talking a
little bit about the program again and
how we've changed I mentioned how in the
first ten years of program it was mainly
about equipment purchasing and then we
had what I call sign of the middle
period of HPP which is 2012 to 2016 and
we move the shift to keep to both
capabilities and healthcare coalition's
in 2012 through what we called a
five-year project period of our grant
and we gave guidance at the beginning of
that five-year project period with the
idea that it would be helpful for our
awardees to have a longer term guidance
of what was being expected of them for
five whole years so we did that and some
of the things that we did were following
the the slide now the capabilities were
really focused on aligning HPP with the
what we call our sister program which is
CDC's the public health emergency
preparedness program to integrate
medical and public health system
preparedness the CDC program focuses on
preparing health departments at the
local and state level whereas we focused
on preparing healthcare facilities and
then the healthcare delivery system in
the United States well we had heard
prior to this was that because the
programs were not really aligned very
well the public health departments were
preparing for one thing and the
healthcare facilities were preparing for
another and often at odds with each
other so we knew we had to put out
guidance that have both of those
different systems somewhat marching in
the same direction and I think we fairly
succeeded at that during that 2012 to
2016 period we also put out performance
measures as with any grant program and
we set a high bar for the awardees but
the program measures that we set were
what we consider be very subjective with
self-reported Likert scale measures that
were not really easy to be validated and
didn't tell us very much about what this
program was doing in terms of really
building preparedness the third was that
we establish regional healthcare
coalition's around the country and they
did certainly foster collaboration among
competitive health care entities and
really what we looked at from that 2012
to 2016 period was we brought the people
to the table we got them there and we
got them exchanging business cards well
in advance now we need to take them to
the next step where they're actually
responding together and they're truly
gelled as groups and they are now
communicating with each other both
before and during emergencies and then
the last case was we really had an
effort on kind of focusing a wordy
burden to make sure the awardees weren't
considering this just to be a grant
program and checking the boxes of a
grant program but we're really focusing
on the preparedness aspect of it using
the grant funds obviously for that
purpose so we moved we changed things a
little bit and the what we call current
projects area which again this past July
and we did refine our capabilities which
run the prior two streams that we just
walk through really to distinguish the
difference between medical and public
health activities so remaining keeping
them aligned very much together but the
prior feedback we've gotten was that for
the most part the healthcare and the
public health capabilities seem to be
kind of the same and we wanted to really
be able to distinguish what the medical
and healthcare delivery systems role is
in preparedness we improved our
performance measures by requiring all
healthcare coalition's in the country to
do the same what we call exercise in a
box it's a low notice event is on our
website and no notice exercise where the
evaluation criteria and the evaluation
forms are in the box essentially and
that exercise doesn't cost any money for
the coalition to develop they can just
decide to open it up and within a few
hours begin doing the exercise and we
face our performance measures now on
that exercise so that we can really
compare apples to apples across the
country and have some much more
objective data that's numeric based or
numeric value not just like our scale
measures in terms of healthcare
coalition's like I said we really want
to operationalize these coalition's and
get them now respond
together during emergencies not just
getting to know each other and what we
found with that was a lot of our
coalition's were very different across
the country which is good and very
important because you have to make sure
that the coalition's can meet the local
flavor of the town or the region that
they're in but at the same time some of
our coalition's didn't have two
hospitals in it some of them didn't have
local public health departments or
emergency management agencies and some
of them didn't have emergency medical
services in it and in our mind if you
only have one hospital you can't be a
coalition because there's no other
healthcare facility to rely on during an
emergency whether that's just needing
some of their resources meeting some of
their personnel to come and help you out
or whether that's evacuating and moving
your patients to them you also need to
have Emergency Management to provide you
those basic resources such as fuel and
other things you need to have Public
Health because while a safe that Public
Health convenes in a great way a lot of
the healthcare system partners and then
in the last piece you need to have
emergency medical services because no
matter what emergencies require require
movement of both logistics and personnel
and patients which obviously EMS is is
ideal for and last but not least we made
a huge effort this project period to
make sure that the funding was even
though our awardees or at the state
Public Health Department level that the
funding was trickling down to where it
was intended which is the healthcare
delivery system and not getting stuck in
initiative just at the public health
department which is honestly what the
set program the CDC public health
emergency preparedness program is aimed
to do this is more of a graphical
depiction of what a healthcare coalition
is as I mentioned we now have these four
core members that you'll see in the more
bold writing in the graphic and with the
icons the bigger icons in the graphic
those are hospitals emergency medical
services emergency management and public
health but they're not the only
important members the reason we call
them core members is that every single
coalition and community really has these
not every single community has a real
health center or you know a academic
institution or other kinds of things
that you might see here even a
behavioral health center so we wanted to
make sure that we were leaving the
flexibility to the coalition to
determine their right size and structure
and not
making the requirements to ridges if the
coalition doesn't work for rural America
where we know a lot of this will work
for many of the more urban or suburban
places so there is some flexibility
built in but we're very very very
convinced that you must have at least
those four core members to really be a
functional health care coalition in
terms of who's in these coalition's we
have about right now 476 healthcare
coalition's throughout the country
and inside of them they're about 30,000
members and I want you to think of a
member as an organization not a person
so what we're showing here in this graph
is what we call for lack of a better
term our penetration rate inside of
healthcare coalitions 85% of all
hospitals in the United States are part
of healthcare coalition's 82% of local
health department's 56% of local
emergency management agencies and 27% of
emergency medical services are part of
healthcare coalition's and you'll see
the other members that are very
important as well but again much lower
numbers as a results the fact that again
not every single community does have
them so not every community will have
them in the coalition since we started
coalition in 2012 we've had a 92%
increase in part in participation rate
in coalition's now when I say we started
coalition's in 2012 that is exactly that
HTP required them beginning in 2012 but
we do have some coalition's around the
country that isn't around a lot longer
than that very for thinking areas that
decided right after the 9/11 terrorist
attacks that getting health care working
together and not just on their in their
own individual silos was very important
we have some very mature coalition's
have been around for decades and and
truly we look to those as medications
best practices I want to bring to your
attention as for Tracy our Tracy stands
for the technical resources Assistance
Center and information exchange
we know that preparedness is not a
revenue-generating department anywhere
especially not in healthcare facilities
we spend money we don't generate money
and therefore it's very very very
difficult to get the appropriate
resources dedicated to preparedness we
recognize that and we wanted to make
sure that
weren't having anyone reinvent the wheel
essentially I remember being a
healthcare emergency manager for a large
hospital system in in New York and being
asked right after Katrina to write a
hurricane evacuation plan for all of our
hospitals and you know this was
obviously there were internet in those
days but again there was nothing like
Tracy so I started with a Google search
to see if any hospital had just
hopefully puts their hospital evacuation
planned evacuation plan in there which
is obviously very different than a fire
evacuation plan the goal in a fire
evacuation plan or structural evacuation
plan it should just get your patients
out the front door and then you'll
decide what to do with them but in a
planned evacuation plan you want to have
a destination mapped out for those
patients really before you start moving
them and and and really you know I
identify what the triggers are for
beginning to put that plan into motion
because in some cases that can be the
most difficult decisions and so there
was nothing for me to go to I couldn't
find anything on Google to help me get
started so we started writing this from
complete scratch and ever since then I
was thinking myself wouldn't it be
wonderful if all of us emergency
managers Ishrat healthcare you know who
all have these big binder sitting on our
desks and having these electronic files
on our desktops could just put this all
somewhere so that everybody else can
access this and and really figure out
how to begin using it it might not be
perfect for me and I might even do some
major adjustments to it but just a place
to start would be phenomenal so that's
really in a nutshell what Tracy is it's
a place to find technical resources and
those resources include you know a
collection of both the disaster listed
that we get obviously in partnership
with the National Library of Medicine it
includes expert reviews as subject
matter expert reviewed topic collections
where really we know that in many cases
emergency managers are not academically
read journal articles so we really have
our SMEs go through and try to pick out
from many of those journal articles I
highlight kind of the main point or the
key summary and go through and really
figure out which of those resources and
if that are must-read is that if you
only have a few minutes go with these as
opposed to you know if you have more
time go with some of these other ones
and like I said using real life
tools and experiences and highlighting
some of those tools and templates and
other kinds of documents that would just
be incredibly helpful as a starting
point so there's a tremendous amount of
material that is all searchable on ask
for Tracy ask for Tracy is a free
resource but yet if you're not the kind
of person that likes to do searches on a
website we also have our Assistance
Center and they are available to provide
personalized support both by a toll-free
number that's on the screen as well as
on by email and the other thing that's
nice about Tracy is sometimes the answer
has never really been started you can't
find anywhere it's a starting point for
your plan or your your tool that you
need to develop and that's where tracing
and then take our subject matter experts
or stable subject matter experts and do
some personalized support to find a way
to get you started whether it's a white
paper on a very specific topic that
hasn't really been explored much in the
literature or in the great literature
and and find a way to get you started we
did a lot of that during Ebola where
there wasn't nearly enough to go by very
few hospitals had plans that really
would have worked for Ebola they had
infectious disease plans but more on the
endemic flu side not on the specific
requirements of a bio containment unit
and so we did a lot of that Bend and
we've done a lot of that since then and
many other emergencies that have come up
because the disasters would keep
occurring in this country lately never
really cease to amaze me and I'm sure
many of you and the last piece of Tracy
is the ie piece the information exchange
and this is a password-protected area
for discussion among users it's more
like message boards and in areas where
if you're having a problem and you want
to reach out to the community of users
and Tracy you can post a thread and
other people can respond to your thread
and you can actually share more
privately shared documents that way if
you don't want them kind of posted on a
website or if you just want to have a
you know examples that we've seen lately
is things about staffing you know how
certain hospital staff is a staff their
units during disasters and those are
things that may be from a business
perspective you don't want to put up on
the World Wide Web but you might just
want to float around ideas with other
individuals that happen to be reading
the answer may
exchange and may be willing to more
privately share information with you
want to talk a little bit about the
Centers for Medicare and Medicaid
Services emergency preparedness rule
because this is where I feel like the
audience on this call might get a
tremendous amount of both questions as
well as areas where you can really be of
assistance the emergency preparedness
rule is the first time that the Center
for Medicare and Medicaid Services has
put out a rule about emergency
preparedness and this is a very very
broad rule that applies to 17 different
provider and supplier types so really
you know about 70,000 different
different healthcare facilities and
organizations are impacted by this rule
and its goal is to really set baseline
levels of preparedness and when I say
baseline I mean baseline level of
preparedness the CMS rule is a wonderful
wonderful starting point because as I
said we never had this we've never had
this in the past we all have seen the
picture that would happen with health
care facilities following Katrina and
we've seen health care facilities get
more and more prepared but we certainly
are not where we need to be there is
still a lot of health care facilities
maybe not as much Hospital now but other
kinds of facilities nursing homes
dialysis facilities in more recent
emergencies like hurricane sandy that
just didn't really have a plan they
didn't have any planning for emergency
preparedness of what they were going to
do if they shut down and where they were
going to direct their patients to make
sure that there was a fairly seamless
continuity of care for them so this is a
new rule that will be incorporated into
the routine survey that CMS does of all
of us providers and suppliers its goal
is to establish a baseline level of
preparedness where we think is the best
kind of part of this rule is is that it
doesn't just say that the facility
itself needs to have a preparedness plan
and needs to exercise that plan but they
must integrate that into the community
planning and so I like to think of that
as a code word for be part of a
healthcare coalition really know what
the plans are for your entire region
make sure they know your plans and
exercise those hands together know how
to get in touch with all of your spouse
care facilities in your region and if
don't operate as an island is really the
best way to say this
and again we were looking to do this to
improve the continuity of care across
the entire healthcare system and also to
increase executive level by in
healthcare executives are incredibly
busy they have a lot of financial
pressures on their plates and as I
mentioned before emergency preparedness
is not by any means a revenue generating
program so we want to make sure that
executives are aware at all times of the
level of preparedness our facility has
as well as their region because in some
cases is going to take those those
employees of those organizations and
those healthcare facilities to work for
the healthcare coalition and in some
cases that's that's an in-kind
contribution that's not going to be paid
for your time is going to be paid for to
help write the regional plans or to go
to a regional meeting but it is in the
best interest of the health care
facility that you work for because
having a more prepared region is
obviously going to do wonders for your
own facility so we wanted to use this as
a lever also to increase executive
buy-in for preparedness we think again
if they mentioned that this creates a
tremendous amount of opportunity for
healthcare coalition's healthcare
coalition's in many cases are sort of in
some ways struggling to service to show
their value to those executives they
show their value to the emergency
managers that often sit on those
coalition's but many of the c-suite
folks whether it's the medical officer
senior medical officer or the chief
nursing officer are not aware of what
these coalition's are and what they can
potentially do and this is the case
where again we vision that the
healthcare coalition's can really
participate in the planning of the
individual healthcare facilities are
impacted by this rule helps them write
their plans help them exercise their
plans which does two things number one
it helps the preparedness of that
organization but it also helps the
coalition's preparedness because they're
going to know what the plans are that
individual facility and they're going to
have those relationships built in it
also may increase the financial
sustainability of these coalition's
because rather than hire a high-priced
contractor to perhaps go and do this
work if the coalition does it I bet it
would be for less money and you might
get a very high-quality product as a
result
a lot of times we know that the
coalition's themselves don't have
tremendous amounts of time on their hand
as I said the funding is limited and
then many of them don't have a
tremendous amount of full-time employees
able to just sit down and start crafting
plans from scratch and that's again
where ask for Tracy comes in when they
have a dedicated rule CMS rule page that
has a tremendous amount of resources
that can help the 17 provider and
supplier type with what what is they
need to meet the requirements and the
conditions of participation for the rule
again it's going to need to be
customized and tailored but it is at
least a starting point and last but not
least we have worked with the Center for
domestic preparedness which is through
the Federal Emergency Management Agency
FEMA to offer a health sector emergency
preparedness course that will provide
the healthcare providers and suppliers
with training to achieve the four core
emergency preparedness elements that are
outlined in the rule most courses at the
Center for domestic preparedness are
called residence courses where you
travel to the CDC in Anniston Alabama
and you take these courses for a week
and you travel home and the travel is
all free and the government funds it but
we didn't think that would be the right
thing to do for this course because
healthcare executives again are
incredibly busy and they don't have the
time necessarily to travel for lengthy
periods of time so instead we created a
non-resident course where the course
will travel to you if a coalition and a
group of hospitals can get it your face
essentially secures his face and
coordinate invites for other local
healthcare facilities not just hospitals
at any of the 17 providers the fire-type
to also attend then FEMA is willing to
send some of its trainers to come up
with all the equipment all the supplies
everything that's needed for the course
and host the course there it's an
eight-hour course and it's really
designed to help understand those
requirements that are outlined in the
rule and develop the skills and
knowledge to achieve those requirements
and develop plans and everything to
achieve those requirements the only
again responsibilities for the course
post are to provide a classroom or an
auditorium recruits those the audience
which is the 17 different CMS provider
types and provide a point of contact
from that host organizations to the
trainer at the FEMA site and then they
will certainly work very hard to get
that that course out to you the course
just started in November and there have
already been nearly 2,000 individuals
trained in that course throughout the
country so it's moving at a fairly rapid
pace and with that I'd like to turn it
over for questions so thank you fabulous
and then have you been monitoring
questions hi yes we do have a couple of
questions in the Q&A pod one was how
does aspirin vision sustaining over 450
HTC's with an emphasis on response so
what we made a response is maybe a
little bit different than the other
response entities we don't expect
healthcare coalition's to travel like
them sirens to a scene and you know
really technically hands-on response
what you what we do mean by response is
that the coalition's are whether it's in
a virtual way or together all in one
conference room or one operation center
that they're all getting on and they're
sharing information with each other
during an emergency and they're
participating in strategic planning
during that emergency so what we mean by
that is we can many of us probably
consider this year's flu season to be an
emergency that the levels of patients
were just as high if not higher than
2009 h1n1 and some cases the acuity is
less as well so it was it was a really
tough flu season and we had coalition's
that came together early on in the fall
and said we see certain things happen
here are triggers when we see certain
things happens we are going to implement
standard policies across the entire
coalition on visitations so in other
words no children under age 16 can come
to the hospital once we see these
identified figures and we will all put
that in place on the same day because
the last thing you want our patients
taking which oh so they're going to go
to based on inconsistent policies across
the board during emergencies so that
those are what we mean by response we're
not talking about coordination of
necessarily vetting of resources it's
important to know from a situational
awareness perspective who has what
resources available but the coordination
of those resources and the movement of
them around and the tracking of them is
not always going to be a coalition
responsibility in some cases coalition's
are very mature and are doing that but
in other cases that's still a local
government responsibility to get that
she's done ok thing another question we
have is could I find AC EMP for it for
an FQHC so city code that yes you if you
go on as for Tracy I can't speak this
into lakes on on the site right now but
I believe for each of the provider types
we do have at least some examples of
tools and templates out there and if
you're really looking for a specific one
for a specific kind of facility such as
a senator qualified health center and
you don't see one there we can certainly
reach out to our partners at first and
try to get one of those for you and then
posted
as for Tracy so that everybody can see
it so please visit the a sport racing
website and to see if what you need is
there and if not I'm sure that's
something we can help find for you and I
just put the link to the CMS rule from
the F / Tracy page into the chat box so
I know that some people are on the Q&A
box and some people are in the chat box
so if that's where it is
thank you okay another question we have
is do you have any insight or comment on
the transfer of the SMS program to a
spur so so for those who are not
familiar with with that transfer that
transfer means basically that the SNS a
strategic national stockpile program
that is part of CDC will be moving under
a fur and and really this makes perfect
sense in the in the idea that the
purpose of the office of the assistant
secretary for preparedness and response
is to coordinate to be federal
governments in the emergency support
function 8 during a healthcare emergency
we have a higher logistics division here
within after and we have in addition to
that health personnel through the Public
Health Service as well as the National
Disaster medical system that we often
deployed during emergencies and did many
deployments during their recent
hurricanes so from a logistical
standpoint it made more sense to kind of
put all of the emergency logistics
during a healthcare emergency under one
organization which is obviously led by
dr. Kadlec dr. Robert Kadlec who again
it really serves as the federal
government is the commander during a
during a public health emergency okay
thanks another question we have is I'm
in an RHC
and the end a department of four the
hospital the clinic is off campus from
the hospital do I still need to have my
own preparedness plan or can I use a
hospital III again I am NOT CMS so I
don't want to guide you the wrong way on
this but
certainly we can put you in touch there
there is a Serbian Certification group
at CMS can probably answer your question
on that I would to take a guide you in
the wrong the wrong way and if you need
any connections for that you can feel
free to reach out through the NLM group
and they can put you in touch with us
and we can put you in touch with PMS but
yeah I think it's best if you work with
CMS on that one okay thanks are there
resources available for local emergency
management agencies to better understand
their roles and responsibilities with
the new CMS guidelines the first
specific resources and roles and
responsibilities again I would just say
with that that office of emergency
management are not really any are really
covered providers underneath the CMS
rules they don't receive Medicare
Medicaid funding so they don't they
don't have any conditions of
participation officially through the
rule but that said the office of
emergency management and as an integral
partner in healthcare coalition's have
planning experts and know their
community's incredibly well and they
know how to bring together various
different organizations within their
communities so to say that they don't
have a formal role meaning that they
don't have a required role it's correct
but yes I do believe they have a
responsibility to assist a health care
facilities both through the coalition
and in working with their local public
health department to make sure that all
of the providers that are covered under
this rule know where to begin know how
to get started and and are kind of being
in some cases coached on emergency
preparedness because we have heard from
many different health care facilities is
you know small dialysis the center is
certainly not the the large chains but
small ones they have an administrator
who may be this is going to be five
percent of her responsibilities or his
or her responsibility to do and she
doesn't even know where to get started
one of them put it to us in a funny way
so they don't even had a cell emergency
preparedness 101 begin writing a plan
and so that's where those of us that
have been in planning for practically
our whole lives we can really lend a
hand and really really help out and it's
going to pay dividends for the Office of
Emergency Management
in local communities when there is an
actual emergency if those plans are both
good plans quality written plans well
trained on the plan those facilities are
well trained on the plan and then
they're well exercised because they're
going to have less of the crises on
their hands to deal with when there is
an actual emergency
okay thanks that's all the questions I
can see right now if anyone else has
needs more questions or clarifications
please go ahead and put them in the chat
pod so Jen maybe you already asked this
I've also been looking online for some
answers there was a question do you have
a link for how to register for the
healthcare sector emergency preparedness
course I have a flyer for a local one
but couldn't figure out how to register
yes so we can actually send to you it's
actually an email of an individual at
the CDP I can actually send to you his
email address and you can push that out
to all the listeners on face off okay
you probably already got that this is
great I'm really excited about this so I
had a question in you you showed while I
put up the URL for the Esper Tracy
website and you were talking about the
information exchange and how we can go
on there and ask questions
password-protected so I assume that that
you know just not just anybody can get
into Esper Tracy in that way so what's
the process for that and who do you let
in yeah I mean so really the whole
purpose for for the password piece is to
make sure that number one lots of spam
isn't going to come into the information
exchange and to make sure that people
sort of are who they say they are when
they really a verification process of
your email when you register but we are
not picky as but we don't say oh because
you have a you know Oh calm rather than
a gov or that evening you we can't let
you in if you are really and truly
involved in healthcare preparedness or
Public Health preparedness on a
preparedness side there will be no
problem getting into it okay great
really it doesn't ask for Tracy and fill
out the form and exactly okay yeah
all right we do have one more question
that just come in how many drills and
what type are required for the CMS rule
my understanding was one EMP activation
and one community-wide type drill this
is a important part about the community
wide type drill is that it does not
necessarily need to be completely
separate you need to demonstrate your
you know if you do an emergency
preparedness drill in your own facility
and there are other facilities
exercising at the same time and then you
engage other facilities and that more of
a regional drilled that that's
sufficient we have a lot of folks
thinking they have to do one one
individual facility drill and then later
on a community drill but the best way to
leverage your time precious time here is
to be sure that when your community
drill is taking place you also exercise
your own individual plan at the same
time and take that kind of exercise into
your facility if that makes sense okay
and the same person just asked for a
little bit of a clarification do you
mean several of all my sites at the same
time so you say all my sites set to me
and again maybe I'm reading this wrong
but it sounds like all of a wone
corporate health system sites that's not
necessarily a community-wide drill
community my drill needs to make sure
that it incorporates the the emergency
response system so that is obviously
local government and other kinds of
agencies as well and not just he knows
if you have five clinic sites all owned
and operated by the same entity that
you're exercising all of those at the
same time they have to engage your
community partners okay that's all I
have thank you okay well Melissa do you
have some final words you want to offer
or yeah I just want to thank you all so
much for your time I know it's tough to
devote an hour to anything but I think
if this is a wonderful opportunity with
Stacey asked me if I would do this I
thought you know this is such a unique
group to be able to speak with and
you're all in such a position to really
be able to help the audience that we're
trying to message do that often is
really difficult for us to get out to
everybody so I really do want to thank
you and again I would just appreciate
keeping the lines of communication open
either through
through directly through the NLM or
through the HPP mailbox which is HPP at
HHS gov I do feel another question in
there about whether or not the health
sector runs your fairness course
incorporated ticks or the adaption of
the nursing home incident command system
and it does have but the court does have
a large incident command component to it
although that's not the only component
of the course okay and yes I second all
of these excellent informative
presentation and I just want to remind
people on this call who might be at the
prep summit that both efforts and NLM
will have a booth at the prep summit I
think we're right across from each other
so you can run back and forth to each of
our booths and pick up information we
will have two presentations the National
Library of Medicine will have will be
offering our disaster information
specialization you can get that while
you are at the conference so that's
exciting for us to be able to offer the
courses to allow you to receive that
certification while you're there and
we'll also be talking about our disaster
research response initiative with the
National Institutes of Environmental
Health will also be next up in two weeks
at the Public Library Association
meeting with the with a booth as well so
that's places you can find Traci Aspern
and NLM so oh thank you so much
everybody for staying on for the hour
and stay warm don't channel too much at
one time and we'll see you again thank
you